prendila non me ne frega un cazzo no
[ __ ] chi è chi sei non mi [ __ ]
la videocamera tutto stronzo non puoi
cadere non puoi godere
molte le grandi siamo ragazzi mi è
cascata la videocamera che demente non
me ne frega un cazzo che non ci hai due
dita per spostarti al buio e bisogno
della tua videocamera ma va non vedo un
cazzo ma va porca tra una videocamera
una cosa da una cosa devi portare una
non è difficile come ci arrivo di so
devo scendere così ma appunto potrebbe
cadere non cambiava nulla sai che devi
proviamo ad andare avanti ragazzi non
non vedo un cazzo cos'è c'è qualcosa che
sta sfonda ragazzi io io vado dove c'è
luce perché non vedo una mazza di niente
il che rende il gioco 20 volte più
inquietante di quanto non sia già
abbastanza da solo ho perso due dita ho
perso anche la videocamera non c'è più
un cazzo da perdere è chiaro c'è gente
che gira non si sa come nel mani nei
manicomi a a random non si sa perché non
si sa perché passant uno che cazzo vuoi
tu
togliti brutto strato va a far compagnia
spencer c'è io io non la capisco stadi
non la capisco ma se vuoi passare chiedi
pa vj di posti cazzo io mi sposto oddio
santissimo ragazzi chi cazzo sei tu
ragazzi che poi c'è gente che seduta nei
tavoli non si sa perché se sei un figlio
della madonna
senti c'è mica la videocamera mia novero
perché mi è caduta usciamo di qua perché
tanto la videocamera non è qui da
qualche parte la tutela troverò ragazzi
non temete sarà dovrebbe essere qualche
parte qua sotto comunque tipo che è
accaduto qualcosa e io non ho capito che
eccola eccola l'ho trovata prendi la
maledizione allunga su ghiaccio devo
fare il giro c'è di qua non puoi
prenderlo già fi bravo ce l'abbiamo
fatta ragazzi abbiamo st videocamera
maledettissima
lo sapevo ci avrei scommesso qualsiasi
cosa brutti stronzi
la gang bang peggiore del mondo devo
tornare dove mi se anche scassata
[ __ ] videocamera nuova phillips
va beh vediamo di chiudere perché sennò
mi inculano ovunque ragazzi io penso che
l'obiettivo di sti tizi sia quello di in
gruppo armi da dietro no non le
interferenze no eh
capiamoci le interferenze no no perché
se ci mettono pure quelle se non son
cazzi miei
c'è già non vedo una mazza di mio cioè
come faccio tante volte di tornado vero
prima vero perfetto tanto qua sopra non
ci arrivano sono stronzi non
arrampicarsi aspetto ragazzi preparatevi
al ru continue in outlast il chiostro
cazzo di vetro rotto fantastico non
aveva ambizioni migliori comunque
ragazzi in qualche modo devo risalire
anche se non ho capito come ai fatti
tirandomi suo fantastico ragazzi amo
troppo forti devo soltanto allora io non
mi abbia avventurerei nel buio cerchia
padre martin amministrazione si perché
padre martin è arrivato fin qua senza
aiuti senza nulla ed è un prete questo
che mi spaventava ragazzi di importante
che costa videocamera ci pesa perché
sennò cos'è ok calmi non è che non è
morto nessuno calmi devo a girare sto
punto prima di cadere di sotto ma un
deficiente fermi che spetta un attimo se
ok mi sono fatto malissimo
buongiorno non mi fai nulla vero cosea
solo un'uscita solo uscita grazie io io
comunque non è questa per te io io
chiudo tutti gli altri perché non si sa
mai
come sai di non essere un paziente come
sai di non essere un [ __ ] non lo so
amico mio vado avanti perché mi
costringono vabbè qua siamo in una parte
abbastanza accettabile del manicomio
cioè questa mi sembra
mi sembra di essere tornato più o meno
all'inizio infatti questa dovrebbe
essere la zona per sani mentali perché
cazzo c'è l'obeso io non c'ho
fottutamente parole e ovunque non è
possibile
che sia ovunque ragazzi [ __ ] e
muoviti sbagliavo i tassi perché ho
mollato la tastiera giustamente ma
[ __ ] aspettate chiudo aspettate
chiudo sì sì sì pranzo di merda ragazzi
dove devo andare dove ha sfondato di
sicuro ne sono convinto però forse i caf
accio prima ad aspettare altri orsi e si
si i condotti non ci arriva non ci
arriva perché obeso sì buongiorno anche
tutti sta nascondendo vero siamo siamo
amici anche mi sono seconde perché mi
guardi così se gira pure la testa
dall'altra parte
sei veramente figo poi puoi andar giù e
vai giù bravo bravo così bene siamo
all'inizio siamo siamo all'inizio
cioè io io all'inizio ero qui me lo
ricordo ai ragazzi abbiamo fatto tutto
sto gere quello è l'inizio
cioè io io ero il primo spavento che mi
sono preso da quello dall'altra parte ci
siamo arrivati dov'ero prima mio addio
ho fatto cinque forse sei non lo so sai
tu sì mi hanno detto di dirti che la
chiave per la casa di dio sei bellissimo
volevo dirtelo e nella sala fronte una
sala proiezioni dietro la luce
fantastico è un'uscita uscita
ovviamente chiusa un calcio non fa mai
male è però non ci provare ovviamente
non si sa mai che riusciamo uscire prima
addosso posto non vorrei mai quarto
cazzo sei figo ragazzi questo è il
fratello di jason è veramente bello mimì
sony un pezzo no eh va beh io io vado
nella sala proiezione non ci tengo
incontrarti spero vivamente di non dover
entrare dentro fantastiche delle
interferenze la videocamera ragazzi ci
mancava veramente sono quelli infatti
devo entrare qui dentro
grandissimi è la sala proiezioni
comunque questa devo trovare la chiave
dove era era di essere anche i ragazzi
[ __ ] che il crostino colloquio
finanziato a stai trasmettendo no grazie
non sono interessato a vedere
sei molto gentile a tentare di
intrattenermi ma non voglio vedere film
non sono interessato grazie forse
ragazzi e proprio nella sala proiezioni
ma al sangue non promette per niente
bene
c'è un cazzo vero perfetto raga io non
so dov'è andato il tizio di prima
io non lo auguro perché un sollievo ha
detto non lo apro devo trovare st
fottutissima chiave non è così difficile
e cos'è siamo nella sala proiezioni no
non ancora ragazzi ci siamo quasi credo
sia questa sì lì è la chiave hai per
caso acceso tu prima
no perché c'è un tizio che accendo per
forza [ __ ] ragazzi qualcuno mi
spiega come entro lì dentro adesso non
lo so devo fare accuse a di qua ci siamo
arrivati ad una inutile raga come fa
centrali dentro si aperto sto porta
grandissimo non si sa perché forse mio
dio devo fare dovunque vado ragazzi devo
farla acrobata perché sennò non è
normale come faccio quando devo a
lanciarmi sulla ringhiera ragazzi vai
così se grandissimo c'è un tizio qui c'è
un tizio che è che manda su infarti
no è uscito bene così allora l'ho presa
la chiave ci siamo io mi butto dal
balcone per essere sicuro però qualcosa
mi dice che mi ammazzo lo stesso quindi
devo tornare indietro ragazzi devo
tornare indietro ragazzi succederà
qualcosa io sono sicuro sono sono con
via spetta a chi cazzo c'era qui dentro
prima
[Musica]
ascoltami zio non è nulla di personale
ma ci ha messi vico a posto qui dentro
no perché mi serve ragazzi c'è c'è
qualcuno io non ce la faccio più la
porta l'uscita aperta la porta d'uscita
è fottutamente aperta posso scappare di
qua non ci credo lo [ __ ] lastre
grande cioè il tizio andato dall'altra
parte lo [ __ ] di brutto ma di brutto
proprio c'è mio dio non ci posso credere
ce l'ho fatta anche st portare alla
stessa che c'era all'inizio cioè io va
beh sto passando dall'altra parte di
tutti i luoghi chi cazzo è quello senti
allora io non ho cattive intenzioni
l'omnia non ti avvicinare bruscamente
allora amico mio
la porta e quella devo aprirla ciò vuol
dire che devi stare fermo devi stare
fermo devo solo aprire la porta sola
aprì la porta
ok non me ne frega un cazzo se c'è il
birillo di fuori devo aprire
sì sì sì sì non ci credo non ci credo
non ci posso credere
sono veramente non ci sto sognando
ragazzi e non mi ha ucciso non mi ha
inglobato non ci posso credere è
fantastico cioè mi sarei aspettato da un
momento all'altro che mi salta addosso
ma non l'ha fatto
non ci posso veramente credere no fermo
fermo dove dove vai
dove pensa di andare ragazzi è pieno di
gente che non raggiungerò mai perché si
chiude le porte alle spalle e siamo in
cucina ragazzi siamo in cucina dove la
nutella
ci sarà da qualche parte sono sicura
datemi la sua [ __ ] nutella chi è
quello c'è un tizio che sta guardando
fuori dalla finestra sembra melo pazzo
degli altri perché almeno non sta
facendo cose strane senti zio mi fai
guardare fuori dalla finestra con te
perché non c'è il naso sei parente di
voldemort
ma poi non sto a rompergli le balle
perchè tanto devo trovare padre martin
prima o poi lo troverò quel
maledettissimo stronzo devos trovarlo ok
perfetto di qua siamo dall'altra parte
del corridoio perfetto abbiamo girato il
punto di prima
c'è un team qualcuno si fa una partitina
biliardo novero perché a tut vuoi
giocare a biliardo e la gente questo ce
vole come un dito nel deretano
devo di qua ci passo ci passa ci passo
ci passo amico prega tranquillo e non ti
disturbo ma va ragazzi ci siamo questa
zona completamente nuova devo soltanto
trovare c'è qualcuno qui dentro tutti
che pregano tutti non c'è nessuno che
non prega solo io vado in giro con una
videocamera riprendere
va bene sentite io non voglio
disturbarvi per niente fatte soltanto
attenzione che c'è gente che gira col
birillo di fuori questa posizione qui
non è delle migliori voglio soltanto
dirvi questo venditore porta a porta
vedessi data qualcosa
ragazzi io io sto aprendo le porte mi
sento veramente cos'è qua qua non prega
non prega nessuno ragazzi qualcuno nella
disperazione si è buttato giù di qua si
vede che la paura dei due tizi che lo
prendessero da dietro vabbè comunque
passiamo dall'altra parte perché
ovviamente devo sposare il mio istinto
da apriso persia se non siamo contenti
ragazzi devo entrare qua dentro ci siamo
ragazzi non so dove siamo arrivati però
di sicuro è un corridoio diverso da
prima perché sto scritta non c'era
grande heidsieck nel fantastico ragazzi
ciechi chi è quello stai tenendo cosa
c'è scritto rep
ma la race mettete iscrivere roba sul
muro comunque sei veramente bello mi fa
piacere che vi siete convertiti anche
voi due vedo
e allora finita lì girare col birillo lì
fuori ragazzi è brutta sta situazione
veramente c'è chi è questo tu continua a
parlare che gli oli già registrare
ragazzi questa domanda mistero sarà
fantastico va bene padre martin si è
fatto crocifiggere ed eccola qui
guarderei registrerà lì la mia morte e
la mia resurrezione poi saremo liberi
insieme affinché mori tu a me va bene
non c'è problema amico mio vai vai così
sto registrando non sei più in pericolo
ha riparato l'ascensore chi condurrà la
libertà noi tutti saremo liberi grazie
non è solo padre ma anche tecnico gli
ascensori
e si sta bruciando vivo fantastico ha
dolori prendere scusa mi dispiace se
riprende i miei piedi nel frattempo è un
se prendo la chiave tipo grazie mille
l'ascensore ti porterà all'uscita
principale grazie mille ragazzi non ci
posso credere
vabbè dai io me ne vado tanto non se ne
accorgerà mai che non l'ho finito di
riprendere aprite bastardi aprite bravi
cosi inchinate via po vj io non mi
inchino a voi di sicuro ragazzi devo
tornare indietro assolutamente st
colonna sonora è fantastica dai condotti
ragazzi io sono sicurissimo che tanto in
qualche modo non usciamo perché anche
prima pensavo di essere uscito chi cazzo
ancora al ciccione di merda non ce la
faremmo un ragazzi e cioè ciccione
ovunque anche quando deve uscire c'è il
ciccione non c'è verso
raga come faccio come cazzo fanno sponda
all'altra porta ok ok ok ok ok l'ho
girato la girato divenuto ha girato di
brutto del ho infilato al caf ranzi di
brutto amico mio
dimmi che si apre un cazzo 2 chi o no a
vedevo l'edizione sì sì chiuditi cazzo
dove entrare nella maratona meglio della
maglietta si si io milan ce l'ho fatta
non so cosa aspettarti anche deve
andarsene deve andare non deve trovarmi
assolutamente voglio solo aiutarti amico
io tu mi vuoi mangiare vivo che cazzo
dici
sono andato sì ci credo sì credo di sì
sì grandissimi ragazzi ce l'ho fatta non
so come chiudi st porta mio dio
ok adesso devo deve uscire con calma di
qua non so dove devo andare perché mi
avete chiuso la porta porca tra a
prefetto l'avevo vista questa
grandissima
siamo nella cucina di prima ragazzi sto
praticamente rifacendo il punto di prima
con delle zone che non avevo per niente
visto non mi dire che ti fai male
infatti mio dio né che poi cadere farti
male sempre ragazzi ce la possiamo fare
non è impossibile
devo arriva sì sì non ci credo si chiude
chiudi ti chiudi ti non ci posso fare
le porte sono aperte però perché
all'inizio ero all ero a nell'atrio però
non funzionava l'ascensore spero che
stavolta funzioni è che non mi spunti
nessun medico di me ero qua all'inizio
del gioco ero qua
apri nou dove due vai vai ragazzi dai
ragazzi concluso qui l'episodio sei
video è piaciuto come al solito lasciato
argomento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come in ogni video tratta una
descrizione se ne siete riusciti
iscrivete ci rivediamo il prossimo video
bella ragazzi